[Music]
it's a special edition of ETS late night
roundup as late night hosts and stars
pay tribute to the late Don Rickles we
lost money that we and I love very much
today Jimmy Kimmel sobbed uncontrollably
during Thursday's show the comedians
were very close friends
when my Uncle Frank passed away I called
him and asked him to be the guest at Joe
and which was a tough showman and helped
all of us through it Adam Sandler was a
guest on the show
he said he worshiped Rickles and told a
hilarious story about the first time
they met [ __ ] saw happy gilmore watch
the whole thing Wow amazing how
no-talent can get you in here on The
Late Show Stephen Colbert remembered how
Rickles made him feel he hugged me and
told me I was good and um I felt like a
made man while Seth Meyers shared this
funny memory he just looked at me and
said oh I'm so sorry to hear Saturday
Night Live was cancelled and I was like
Oh wasn't canceled and then he just went
a guy can dream
[Laughter]
there's nothing better than getting
burned by Don Rickles
[Music]
you